deepest betrayal holy [ __ ] i don't know
about this one bro i don't get nervous
now brother what's going on oh i see i
already answered that's why
that's too deep
that's rough
i remember
my husband and i
and another couple
went out fishing
and uh they all started drinking
and i got upset and
said something sarcastic and
my husband
started
hitting me
and
the other couple was standing there
watching and
they didn't do anything to stop him and
it just broke my heart it was
a betrayal
it was a betrayal
how many years were you with him after
that
five
and what was like the breaking point
where you're like i need to leave he
started striking the children
that doesn't mean i didn't love him
he just was a poor soul that
something happened to you
i haven't really had too many but i
think the one i can remember the most
was in elementary school
i had a little friend for like a while
it was like my first ever friend best
friend i would say and uh when we got
into middle school himura just turned
more into more away from me which was
fine friends grow up from like apart
from each other
but i think it's when he started getting
into a different like bigger crowd he
started bullying me more and more of did
things to appease the crowd that was
like cooler i would say
so that was kind of like heartbreaking
for me it was hard because i he
got bullied with me as a kid so i
thought he would understand more
and
didn't happen
i think that
one of my biggest betrayals is actually
my um
my uh
my i was just talking about this with my
friend my stepfather who raised me from
the time i was a year old until i was 10
doesn't talk to me
anymore but i'm friends with like i'm
close with his whole family like they
all still treat me like i'm a
part of the family and uh because he and
my mom got a divorce and uh
it's really affected a lot of my life
and my trust with people and just my
longing for
like deep connection and stuff because
like
we were really really close um you know
when i was a kid so i got
i was like i loved him you know so much
and uh
i try to remind myself that like it's
okay to feel sad because sometimes
things are just really sad and they're
never like not gonna be sad and it's
just like when those waves of sadness
hit you just have to kind of like
just be kind to yourself as if like a
kid was crying like if there was a young
kid crying would you run up to them be
like
stop crying
i mean some people might but like that
would be horrible like super mean um
but yeah that's it
it's really tough
my deepest betrayal was in high school
when i had
a bad experience with a guy at a party
and all of my guy best friends decided
to be friends with him instead of
believing me and being friends with me
i've known these people since i was
really young like 10 years old i've
lived a lot of my life with them
and this guy comes out of nowhere that
they don't even know and they decided
that it would be
more beneficial
for them to be friends with somebody
like that rather than to keep their
friendship with me that had been going
for so long
um probably the betrayal for myself
staying in a relationship that wasn't
doing me any good
um
made me not be true to myself and become
a person that
i wasn't
getting out of that made me realize
that i was betraying myself all along
my deepest betrayal was
i was dating someone for about two years
and
after dating them for so long they told
me that they never loved me
the whole time that i was with them it
really made me feel like
i wasn't going to be able to find love
again and that every time i would try it
would be fake we're all damaged in some
sort of ways and he was damaged in his
own way and i just kind of have to think
that hopefully he did his healing
because that's a tough thing to say to
somebody
so
[Music]
that's rough i guess this is gonna get
deep then that's okay all right so my
deepest betrayal has to be when i was
little i have a sister she happens to be
my half sister however i don't really
make that distinction
i always just view them as my full
sisters never really thought much of it
and then one day
she got asked if i was her brother and
she went ahead and said that
i was only her half brother so i
remember i was probably like four years
old and i remember hearing that and i
just i got really upset
and uh ever since then i just our
relationship has not been the same
honestly there was one time that um
my older brother's friends were gonna
take me to chipotle and they dropped me
off at my house for me to grab some cash
and then they just left me
and it was like a small thing but i've
never forgotten
it hurt me for like a couple of years
did you ever tell your brother
no i didn't tell anybody about it
because i was so embarrassed that it
happened
uh i was raised in a very religious
household um and you've been told your
entire life that
god will take care of you and protect
you and care for you and then and then
people stop being alive at some point
sometimes it's a quick thing when you're
old and sometimes it's a slow thing when
you're young
and you know on the one hand when you're
supposed to be mad at god um but on the
other hand yeah it can feel like a
betrayal that you've been told this
thing your whole life
and
it doesn't always match up with what you
experience in reality and that's really
hard when did you start feeling like
this
a couple of years ago i i
lost a sibling um
yeah if it's someone who's older you can
kind of say yeah well that's kind of the
natural life progression but when it's
not part of the natural life progression
what do you do with that
denial anger bargaining depression
acceptance acceptance oh ho no no no
ridiculous so do you still believe in
god
i do
but there is a point at which you're on
the boat and you've got to see the boat
to the other end
because it's worked this far and you
can't really get off the boat halfway
sometimes you can
i can't i don't i don't have another
boat
and i'd rather be in the boat than in
the water
i think my deepest betrayal
which
isn't necessarily fair to feel
uh betrayed with
in relation to it uh was my father
uh
and the way that he
kind of blew up and
destroyed slash changed all of our lives
i know it was a matter of mental illness
but a
part of me was like you always talked
about how you're going to be there
and your um
your goals and dreams and what you
wanted for us and then you kind of
not only left but took away a lot of
those opportunities for us again it was
not
fully well there was something
wrong with his brain and
that made his judgment impaired he made
some destructive decisions
and then he unfortunately took his own
life
i think mental illness is a huge
betrayal having it passed down through
genes and genetics
by my mom is an involuntary betrayal but
we have a great relationship but i love
her and she helps me in every aspect of
it so it's
it's okay but
it's like kind of something crazy bad
coming from someone you love
um feels like betrayal but
it's involuntary so i can't put a blame
on anybody so that is probably what i
would say
i think probably the deepest betrayal
was let's call it mother nature
my beloved mother was
inflicted with both
lou gehrig's disease and schizophrenia
and so
it took it betrayed
not only her
but the childhood of my brother and i
i think mental illness is a really
important issue that needs to be talked
about
and
mental illness betrays a lot of people
and whether it's the person who has it
or somebody
that loves somebody who has it
i think it's sort of mother nature's
betrayal
so i used to get bullied in high school
when i was in my old high school it got
to a point where it was very serious and
i started thinking very suicidal
and
i
was getting bullied like really bad like
really really bad and i feel like i felt
like the entire school like knew that
there was one night where i was crying i
was just sad i felt so lonely
um
i felt like
i just i just didn't want to be there
like i was just like there's no there's
no point like for what like to live for
what
um that was that like i was that
depressed so i called my friend one of
my good friends
i called her and she lived like really
close to me too and i was like thinking
oh i'm gonna call her you know i'm gonna
tell her if i could come over because i
feel like i'm about to do something
stupid and i don't want to
and
i called her and i'm like hey dee like
uh what are you doing and then she's
like oh wait wait hold up hold up and
i'm like
i'm like no no like stay on the phone
with me just stay on the phone with me
like if you're doing something just at
least just stay on the phone with me and
then
she was just like no no wait hold up
hold up she just clicked on me i
answered her again and she was like wait
jackie you're bugging that just like
kind of like hit my like just punched my
face like just like
like i was just like yeah see like no
one no one cares like from my own friend
like my only friend that i had at the
time i was crying and all that and i was
just not
i was just not feeling it anymore and um
[Music]
i ended up going to the kitchen counter
and i found like where all the
pills were and all that so i just like i
i remember just opening i didn't even
see like what the containers were i just
remember grabbing them throwing them in
my pocket like i had like a big pocket
describing them dumping them just and i
grabbed like a good like five of like
the containers
and
took them off and i i remember i was
even struggling like swallowing them and
i felt nauseous right away
so i like ran to the restroom and then i
couldn't throw up i remember i was there
and i looked at myself in the mirror
after and i was like pale like pale pale
and
i told my brother because he was like
getting ready for bed so he was like
fixing his blankets and everything and
then
i just went in his room and then he's
like what what like he's like why you
look like that and i was just like i
don't
i was i couldn't even say it i remember
i couldn't even say it it wouldn't come
out and then he's like what like he just
looks at me he's like what
and i was just like i took pills and
then he was like
and he just like he literally like grabs
his boots
and like puts on clothes quick and then
like
grabs his keys wakes up my mom and then
that's when it just turns into a whole
mess and my mom's
yeah i i hurt my parents a lot like a
lot
i
yeah i regret that we all learned from
our mistakes
yeah
and then look at you now look at me now
i'm strong and so how did so how did
things get better for you like and what
helped kind of helped
honestly the mental hospital helped a
lot people i feel like when you hear
like mental hospital like i feel like
people think like oh crazy people oh
like they think a lot of weird but it's
it's honestly it helped a lot i met a
lot of cool people too i met a lot of
cool people we did a lot of like we wake
up early ate breakfast and like do fun
activities i got into painting like that
but now i don't even paint
but yeah the mental hospital helped a
lot and so did my mom
i hope you helped a lot yeah she was
there she was
there a lot
yeah
[Music]
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time
you